uh well i'm very happy to be here um to
see that this room is actually quite
full so i'm i'm happy thanks it and i
really thank the organizers because it
really feels nice to be in presence
after so many
time
out remotely
so i'm silver marie i'm i work at
schneider electric
and
and during my
my time there i had the opportunity to
apply
ai on machine learning techniques to
smart grids
building energy efficiency
asset monitoring
you know manufacturing uh improvement
and
many many other tasks so this is my two
seconds ad here we are hiring data
census and data engineers please
have a look online
okay so
uh what about m5 and m5 prime so
when yesterday when i was uh starting to
to write this talk actually i i tried to
remember when it all started and it was
10 years ago
already so
nothing very new but uh you know it's
it's time to to talk about it
so at that time i was developing our
first analytics as a service cloud
platform
and um and it was uh not based on python
it was based on an open source stack
named rapidminer and uh and uh actually
it was embedding a few plugins a bit
like the framework that we saw uh just
before and among those plugins
the
great weka library machine learning in
java
and
m5p was a quite a famous model there
and
you know i was coming from more
traditional
optimization based machine learning
support vector machine or even neural
network classic ones so i was a bit uh
doubtful about
decision trees but actually on some
examples it was working quite nice
so yeah we used it
unfortunately when we migrated from our
first analytics platform to the second
one
in python nothing was there in uh in
cyclone for for this specific kind of
model we could find
you know decision tree regressor
but
not models where the leaf is a linear
model
well let me backtrack a little bit then
about what is actually m5 and m5p
so m5 it's it's from queenland
in
in the 20th century
so the idea is really to it was inverted
it was a bit of a competition between uh
and bremen about all the trees
and uh
his idea was to to
grow a regression tree model like
what was done in carts
same spirit
but trying to get more compact and more
smooth models
so
the idea is really to
uh
it starts exactly the same
you have your data set and you divide um
by finding optimal split um where you
know in in the subparts your target
variable will uh be more and more
constant you know less varying so i
start from the top node and i
try to find an attribute that will
reduce the variability of my that of my
target variable as much as possible i
find it i split and i do it again and
again and again
this is the
main idea of cart and at the
very end of the tree uh you put a
constant value that is the average of
the samples reaching the node
so it starts exactly the same
but what changes is that
afterwards you train a linear model for
all of the nodes in the tree
even winter intermediate ones and you
train it on the samples that reach that
node
also there was this kind of uh
simplification where the linear models
are
simplified by griddling griddingly
removing parameters if they are not
useful
and finally you prune the tree that
means that for example this lm3 node
that is on the right
if its
error
is
almost the same as the combined error of
the two leaves
it's the leaves are pruned away and we
keep only the linear model and you go
backtrack backwards this way so that you
know you simplify the tree and of course
since you know the leaves uh will always
be the best performing in absolute there
is this notion of penalty that you know
two leaves containing two linear models
or two constants have more parameters
than a single linear model so that's how
the
the single one can win and you can
actually prune
so
this is how the pruning is done and
finally there is a last step in the m5
algorithm that is um
smoothing
smoothing is uh using all the trees that
are remaining but in all the linear
models that are remaining in the tree
is basically
to prevent
big gaps between the predictions that
all the leaves are doing
and
for this quinlan
is proposing
some kind of recursively weighted sum of
the model with its parents
across the whole chain chain
so this is how it
looks basically you on a some kind of
non-linear curve you can actually um
uh instead of having constant leaves
such as in
in
in a standard regression tree with with
constant leaf
you you can have linear models uh
piecewise linear models to approximately
in an er curve
you can note that uh you know in in some
places it's uh worse actually but it's
much more simple in term of a
tree of model so that was the
why quinlan was saying that it would be
useful because
i think his sentence is that data
scientists sometimes are more interested
into insights gained from the model than
from the predictive accuracy itself
and that's why he was proposing this
now based on this m5 original uh m5
prime was uh
was a second paper written by wong and
whiten and
the authors basically
thought that
the m5 was not very well documented at
that time and there was no reference
implementation so it was a bit hard for
anyone to actually make it work
so they proposed a few clarifications on
you know some tiny details the proposed
reference implementation
and uh two
improvements that make it easy
to use in the in the real world data
sets
adoption of a specific strategy for
categorical variables and um
tackling a
specific method to handle missing values
and also there seems to be another
improvement it's very fun if someone
knows i would love to to hear the answer
in in this paper they talk about a very
specific uh
improvement that they made that is
supposed to to be very
uh you know reducing the tree size a lot
but actually it's not explained in the
paper it's just stated at the beginning
and at the end
so i would love to see that
i think i found it in the code from weka
there seems to be this kind of new
pruning factor here that that appears
and that is actually as an effect on the
it's if you increase it it's forces the
tree to be pruned more but it's actually
not described in the paper
okay so
[Music]
in term of
python implementation so m5 pi
it was first written for an internal
project
a few years ago
and i opened a pull request in at scikit
learn again a few years ago
however it's you know the
it it was difficult to get the bandwidth
to reach the the
uh required uh quality of code and
documentation
uh
i know a bit because i could compare
with other pull requests that did make
it to the to the core
um
and
but still i was puzzled because you know
i could just stop working on it but
several community members were posting
saying oh i would like to try it i would
like to try it
so
and also i think it's just for sharing
the knowledge if someone wants to
educate uh
people to teach a class about
progression tree he might want to have a
look and
and give an example so anyway so i i
ended up
putting it online i think i think it's
uh
uh it's now online on pi pi zero so it's
a version 0.3.0
and you can find it at this page
i think if i click it i will be able to
show you
here yeah
so that's the yeah it's so recent that
it has no download scores
basically i oh sorry sorry sorry thanks
let me duplicate that
yeah
okay
so i i just included really two examples
um
so
i think the
interesting one here is there
is the one that was
originally in the quinlan queen an
article it's an artificial data set
where you have random variables that are
actually
drawn from linear models
with a condition so you have a variable
that you know when it's above one above
zero you use linear model one and
under zero you get the other linear
model
and on top of this there is some noise
and uh
well when you run uh various kind of
trees so the the traditional cyclic long
decision tree regressor um but also the
uh m5 prime
uh on um
with various uh
settings on it
you can actually see the
the
psychic launch tree which is very big
and
the unpruned m5 p3 which is very big as
well and the pruned and smoothed m5 p3
which is really one split and two linear
models as you would expect
okay i think we are out of time so
i will
sorry
i will
jump above the kb and this this is more
for discussion
okay um
yeah
so
i did not implement all of it
we can talk about it later it's it's
here it's really for the community we
can all
then discuss and see what we want to to
do
and
doing this you know this research about
about how to to create it i
obviously found many more newer
techniques that are
really worth looking at
and that you know you can try compare
and they are already implemented
so
that's uh
that's it for this presentation
thanks a lot
[Applause]
two questions
so i will rephrase the first one
to put a bit of context so when you are
in cyclic land that you use for instance
the trees you have the
mean decrease in impurity that you can
use as a feature importance and
somehow you might use that for to know
what is there how do you
interpret
like how can you just inspect the tree
there and what does it mean i mean like
is it easy or not to uh
to interpret it because you have a
linear leaf everywhere under ah okay so
so
trying to decode what queen line is
proposing is
uh oh your question made my pc stop
[Laughter]
i i think it's um
um there are really two approaches to to
this uh impurity uh
topic
um either you
you you think about uh impurity as the
the resulting one uh using the linear
model and in that case uh it's it's not
vm five algorithm for sure it's it's
rather the one that is implemented in in
like gvm uh you know you would create
you would start from the top and you
would create linear models
uh corresponding to your split and look
at the impurity as as a change as a
variance
of the prediction error
of the linear models
quinlan is not trying to do that
and i think it's so it's quite costly
actually in terms of performance to try
to do that so it's he's really assuming
that anyway if you start from from the
bottom and look just at the impurity in
term of uh
of you know target variable noise um you
will still um be able to
group
neighbor nodes will still
correspond to two places of the space
that are consistent with each other in
terms of input and therefore that can be
grouped consistently in a linear model
so there is no relation between purity
that was used to split and the one that
is resulting at the end of the model
okay and
so the second question was did you have
any benchmark in term of performance
where
uh so i i will refer to the paper in the
paper there are two benchmarks queenland
and the other
the
the one and written
paper so there are two papers in related
to m5 and m5 prime both provide numbers
both use data sets that are uh
open and public
so one of the open issues in the github
repository
for m5 pi is to reproduce the same
numbers and hopefully get the same
results i
i'm not sure we will be able to do that
to get exactly the same numbers for many
implementation differences but at least
it's it's a challenge to at least
reproduce something that is similar
so
i still have more so in terms of
computational uh performance
um
how do you i mean what you gain by
having like linear things uh
if you like compare it to a bike tree or
to a random forest where you have an
ensemble i mean how does it compare like
here oh it you can i mean it's
it's obviously not not something you
want to compare some ensemble method and
non-ensemble metal so what you want to
compare is is his linear
linear model
with linear models so m5 with another
model 3 implementation such as the one
that was displaying at the end i don't
know where it's it's it's off
or with traditional decision tree so
these can be compared and then you can
make ensemble models on all of them
so
actually the
in the packages from a light gbm i think
there is a random version
of the linear model tree
so this one you could compare it with
the traditional random forest
you don't want to compare an ensemble
and non-assembled metal
okay and last questions
are
the m5 prime trees linear splines where
you'll learn the notes
no it's not a spline of
well
i think in the original queenland
article he was referring to another
method where
splines were used but no it's it's it's
uh it's really a linear regression
standard linear regression
yeah okay so thanks again
[Applause]